Here in the 21st century, Capitalism is an
increasingly controversial word. There’s
a growing conversation about how much we should
trust obscenely wealthy people, and whether
or not there should be upper limits placed
on human wealth.
Regardless of where you stand on modern-day
captains of industry, the landscape looks
nothing like it did 150 years ago. Compared
to now, the days of the Robber Barons were
the Wild West – both figuratively and literally.
Across Europe and North America, the late
19th century was a time of industrialization
and ingenuity, and it led to the world’s
inaugural class of independently uber-wealthy
businessmen. Up until the 1800s, it had been
exceedingly rare for any one individual to
amass huge piles of riches without ever sitting
on a throne – that is, until industrialized
economies began to reward men not for wholesomeness
or morality, but for shrewd calculations and
doing whatever was necessary.
Very few men distinguished themselves in these
pursuits like today’s protagonist. He took
a successful family business and built it
into a three-headed empire that still helps
underwrite the world, even 100 years after
his death. He spent decades financing the
major projects and players of the Industrial
Revolution, on both sides of the Atlantic
Ocean.
When governments ran out of money, he didn’t.
His name is JP Morgan, and he paid for the
world you’re living in today.
International Boy of Mystery
John Pierpont Morgan was born into about as
good a situation as anyone could ever hope
for. His paternal grandfather, Joseph Morgan,
was one of the founders of Connecticut’s
Aetna Insurance Company – a successful venture
that grew and evolved over the decades, and
was most recently bought by CVS Health Corporation
in 2017 for $69 billion dollars.
Morgan’s father Junius was a successful
businessman in his own right. Before the birth
of his children, he worked as a partner at
J. M. Beebe & Company, a significant New England
dry goods importer that doubled as one of
the largest retailers in Boston. He would
eventually leave his job to take an even more
glamorous position as the business partner
of famous financier and London philanthropist
George Peabody.
Morgan’s mother was Juliet Pierpont, the
daughter of noted Connecticut poet John Pierpont.
He was best known for his poem The Airs of
Palestine, but also worked as a teacher and
Unitarian Minister, too.
All that is quite the preamble to the birth
of the eldest Morgan child. John Pierpont
Morgan was born April 17, 1837, and he very
much enjoyed the fruits of a privileged New
England childhood. He was a sickly boy, who
suffered from coughs and seizures. However,
when he felt healthy enough, he would attend
concerts and art shows in the northeast. He
enjoyed outings with his parents, where he
told everyone he liked to be called by his
middle name, Pierpont.
At age 11, he enrolled at the forerunner to
Connecticut’s prestigious Cheshire Academy,
where he was allowed to board with the school’s
principal. Three years later, he smashed the
entrance exam for Boston’s English High
School – a school that specifically catered
toward mathematically inclined students who
were looking for a career in business and
finance. He matriculated there in the fall
of 1851, at age 14. His father was grooming
him for the family business.
Unfortunately, before he could finish his
first year at The English High School, young
Pierpont was struck with another medical malady.
Pierpont was incapacitated by a devastating
bout with Rheumatic Fever. Just as an untreated
cold or flu might evolve into a more serious
case of pneumonia, Rheumatic Fever is the
occasional escalation of an untreated throat
infection. According to the Encyclopedia of
Infectious Diseases, Rheumatic Fever only
afflicts about three percent of streptococcal
infections, but it is more common in young
children between the ages of 5 to 14. Ironically,
the disease most often afflicts impoverished
people, because of a lack of proper nutrition
and hygiene.
Pierpont, who was already less healthy than
the average boy his age, was completely sidelined
by the illness. Thus, his father Junius did
what any father would do for a sick child
– he sent him to live by himself in the
Azore Islands, in the North Atlantic Ocean.
Mr. Morgan believed the salty air of the Portuguese
isles would help Pierpont recover from his
condition; ultimately, he stayed on the islands
for nearly a year.
When Pierpont was finally well enough to return
to the US and finish his secondary education,
he felt invigorated by his relatively clean
bill of health. He graduated from The English
High School quickly, earning a reward of…
more school. With his Boston education completed,
Junius next sent Pierpont to Bellerive, a
school in the cozy Swiss town of La Tour-de-Peilz,
just across Lake Geneva from the French border.
Here, he picked up a valuable fluency in French,
which his father believed would be hugely
beneficial to a future business magnate like
Pierpont.
Once he’d mastered French conjunctive, Pierpont
moved on to Germany’s University of Gottingen,
where he mastered his third language in less
than a year. While there, he also formalized
his love of art. Many of us might have loathed
much of the artistic exposure that was forced
upon us as young children, but evidently,
Pierpont couldn’t get enough. He left Germany
with an additional degree in Art History.
With his formal education finally rounded
out, Pierpont went to meet his father in London.
By the mid-1850s, Junius had taken that partnership
with George Peabody; thus, when his son was
ready to enter the work force in 1857, the
London branch of Peabody, Morgan & Company
was the most logical place for a first job.
Love & War
Morgan worked in London for about a year before
returning to New England. Junius trusted his
son as a reliable business auxiliary, which
is how Pierpont landed a position as a clerk
at New York’s Duncan, Sherman & Company
– the American representatives of Peabody,
Morgan & Company.
Even in his 20s, Pierpont showed a keen nose
for profits. One story from his early years
recalls how he bought coffee at a short price
off a New Orleans boat captain who couldn’t
find any buyers for his product. Morgan used
his company’s considerable funds to buy
the coffee, then leveraged his connections
in the area to find buyers that the ship captain
never could. He sold the coffee at a significant
rate of return.
Pierpont had only been in New York for about
a year when he fell in love. In 1859, while
navigating the New York art scene, he met
Amelia, the daughter of a wealthy arts patron
named Jonathan Sturges. Amelia had her own
little nickname, and liked to be called Memie.
Memie and her family were scheduled to do
some travelling in 1859, and a veteran European
traveler like Pierpont was just the expert
they needed. He drew them up an itinerary
that ended in London, then met them over in
The Big Smoke once they were finished. Pierpont
spent two weeks with Memie before escorting
her across the Atlantic, back to New York.
In the modern dating scene, a young single
woman would probably feel that Pierpont was
trying way too hard, but Memie didn’t seem
to mind. She agreed to marry Pierpont in the
following year, during the Spring of 1860.
At age 23, it was the happiest he had ever
been in his young life.
Unfortunately, there were twin disasters right
around the corner. The following winter, in
1861, Memie came down with a pesky cough that
just wouldn’t go away. At the same time,
the American Civil War was just weeks away
from exploding.
Now, you might think a mystery ailment would
be easier to deal with than your entire country
breaking out into armed conflict around you,
but Pierpont evaded service in the Union Army
by paying $300 to a substitute. For that matter,
so did eventual peers John D. Rockefeller,
Andrew Carnegie, Jay Gould, and James Mellon.
For Mellon’s part, he felt some guilt after
the fact about avoiding the War, prompting
his father to write to him that "a man may
be a patriot without risking his own life
or sacrificing his health. There are plenty
of lives less valuable."
We don’t know where young Pierpont stood
on the value of his own life during the first
year of the Civil War; what we do know is
that he desperately wanted to find a cure
for his coughing bride-to-be. After the pair
was married in October of 1861, he recalled
his own successful recovery in the Azores,
a decade earlier, so he made plans to honeymoon
with Memie in the rejuvenating climate of
the Mediterranean. They set up a quaint residence
in Algeria; soon after, while visiting France,
a lung specialist finally diagnosed Memie’s
illness. She had tuberculosis.
Pierpont waited on her constantly, hoping
to improve her condition. Memie actually wrote
a letter to her mother back in the States,
saying “I wish you could see his loving,
devoted care of me. He spares nothing for
my comfort & improvement.”
Sadly, tuberculosis spared very few people
in the 19th century, and Memie was no exception.
She died in February of 1862, four months
after her marriage to Morgan. At 24 years
old, our protagonist was a widower.
Show Me the Money
Pierpont dealt with the loss of his love by
throwing himself back into his work. He returned
to New York, where he had already made quite
the name for himself as a financier. In 1860,
Pierpont had broken away from Duncan, Sherman
& Company, where he had clerked for two years,
and begun representing his father’s firm
in America via his own, eponymous firm: J.
Pierpont Morgan & Company.
The biggest splash he was attached to was
something of a scandal. After his engagement
to Memie, but before their marriage and Mediterranean
retreat, Pierpont had helped finance a nasty
bit of war profiteering, which became known
as the Hall Carbine Affair.
The affair sees a lot of money and a lot of
guns change hands, and can be a bit confusing,
but the simplified version goes something
like this. Morgan was part of a small consortium
called the Union Defense League, alongside
two gentlemen named Simon Stevens and Arthur
Eastman. Eastman bought 5,000 surplus Hall
Carbine rifles from the US Government, which
were considered antiquated and too old for
use because of their age and the caliber of
their rifling. Eastman bought the rifles for
$3 dollars and fifty cents a pop, financed
by Morgan’s money, in August of 1861. The
rifles were almost immediately sold back to
Major General John Fremont and the US government
at more than 600 percent of their original
cost -- $22 a rifle. The sale was made under
the assumption that the rifling had been adjusted
to government standard .58 caliber.
The parties exchanged guns and money, but
the Morgan consortium hadn’t held up their
end of the bargain. The rear breeching chambers,
where infantry would load .58 caliber ammunition
into the back of the weapon, had been adequately
adjusted; however, the actual rifling of the
weapons remained incompatibly sized. Over
the course of the civil war, many infantrymen
blamed these old, defective Hall Carbines
for terrible misfires and accidents, many
of which led to self-inflicted injuries and
potentially preventable amputations.
Almost immediately, there was a US Congressional
investigation. Major General Fremont, who
purchased the guns, had a boss, and that guy
complained to his boss, who complained to
the Secretary of War, and the next thing you
know, the Hall Carbine Affair was born. The
criticism was blistering; newspapers ran dramatic,
muckraking headlines. At one point, the Congressional
Committee on Government Contracts issued a
statement, proclaiming,
“Worse than traitors in arms are the men
who are pretend loyalty to the flag, feast
and fatten on the misfortunes of the nation,
while patriot blood is crimsoning the plains
of the South, and bodies of their countrymen
are moldering in the dust."
Much of this criticism was refuted, years
later, by E. Gordon Wasson’s 1940s investigation,
The Hall Carbine Affair: A Study in Contemporary
Folklore. What isn’t refutable is that Morgan
had made a small fortune off the deal. This
new injection of capital financed several
of the projects he busied himself with, following
the death of Memie. Pierpont went full-throttle
for his father’s company until 1864; it
was then that George Peabody, his father’s
old partner, decided to retire. George Peabody
& Co. was rebranded as J. S. Morgan & Co.
Perhaps to avoid confusion between two similarly
sounding firms, Pierpont took an opportunity
to partner with the more senior Charles H.
Dabney, whom he knew from his European jaunts,
to reform his own house as Dabney, Morgan
& Co.
Now, with all these banking firms, forming
and reforming, you might be wondering just
what it is that Pierpont actually did. It’s
a fair question. Much of what he did was act
as an American agent for his London-based
father, but he did a fair amount of investment
on his own, too. Early on, he traded mostly
in government bonds and foreign exchange,
but as the 1860s went on, he began leveraging
his international contacts to connect old
European money with new American industrialists.
So, as the Civil War concluded, and American
Reconstruction gave way to industrialization
and the Gilded Age, no one on Earth became
more adept at linking railroad barons and
aspiring inventors with deep reservoirs of
investment capital. Early in his career, Pierpont
was often a mere facilitator, connecting financiers
and visionaries for a small cut of the profits.
But as the century wore on, Morgan amassed
a larger and larger fortune, and became wealthy
enough – and powerful enough – to finance
many of these projects on his own.
Becoming the Bank
In the aftermath of the Civil War, Pierpont
had two major life developments. First, he
remarried. His new wife was Frances Louisa
Tracy, another woman he had met in his high-class
social circle in New York. She, too, had a
nickname, and preferred to be called Fanny.
Fanny was not Pierpont’s one true love.
Like many of the American power brokers who
came after him, Pierpont preferred long, intense
hours of grinding out work, brokering meetings,
and travelling abroad. Fanny was completely
his opposite – she was a homebody, who preferred
to spend her time with children and close
friends. Despite their incompatibility, the
two remained married until Morgan’s death,
nearly 50 years later. They had four children:
Louisa, John Pierpont Jr., Juliet, and Anne.
By the birth of his youngest daughter Anne
in 1873, Pierpont’s professional life was
ready to evolve as well. His new partner Dabney
retired in 1871, so Morgan formed a new partnership
with the powerful Drexel family of Philadelphia.
You should probably have this formula down
by now, so it likely won’t surprise you
to learn that their new joint banking venture
was called Drexel, Morgan & Company. Years
later, when Anthony Drexel died, the firm
was rechristened as something that might sound
more familiar to modern audiences: J.P. Morgan
& Co.
For the next 20 years, Morgan’s career seemed
powered by rocket fuel. No longer a mere wealthy
financier living in his powerful father’s
shadow, J.P. Morgan began shaping the numerous
railroad conglomerates that were exploding
across the American landscape. A few simple
loans were enough to keep the coffers full,
but Morgan did much more than that – he
positioned himself at the center of any number
of mergers and reorganizations, growing both
his power and his portfolio.
One of Morgan’s earliest moves in the Railroad
sector was seizing a relatively small line
called Albany & Susquehanna from robber barons
Jay Gould and Jim Fisk. In 1869, Gould and
Fisk had hatched a plan to take a controlling
interest in the railroad by buying a majority
stake. Joseph Ramsey, the President of the
Railroad, blocked their attempt by issuing
thousands of new shares to his supporters;
incensed by the move, Gould and Fisk turned
to more nefarious methods, pressuring a crooked
judge they owned to issue arrest warrants
for President Ramsey. At one point, Fisk literally
got on a train and rode through several Albany
& Susquehanna line stations, beating up rail
workers in an attempt to intimidate the company
into submission. The only thing that stopped
him was a railroad Employee, who pretended
to be a police officer, arrested Fisk, and
took him to jail. When he was eventually released,
Fisk did the same thing all over again, culminating
in a massive railway brawl that had to be
broken up by the state militia.
All of this madness ended with J.P. Morgan,
sensing an opportunity and swooping in with
a $500,000 mortgage payment. Morgan talked
his way into stewardship of the railroad -- he
was elected Vice President of the company
and controller of the road; six months later,
he leased it to the Delaware & Hudson Railroad
company for $490,000 per year. The lease ran
for 99 years.
Morgan was already well off from his family
wealth and his early career moves, but his
involvement with the railroads made him obscenely
rich. For decades, he scoured the exploding
railroad industry for opportunities to, and
it rarely disappointed him. In 1879, for example,
railroad magnate William Vanderbilt approached
him, asking for help in the sale of $250,000
in stock shares for the New York Central Railroad.
He sold all of it, without dropping the share
price by one dollar, which scored him a seat
on the railroad’s board of directors.
In 1880, he was the central figure in a syndicate
that made a $40 million bond sale to finance
the highly anticipated Northern Pacific Railway.
Up to that point, it was the largest transaction
of Railroad bonds in US History.
In 1885, he restructured the New York, West
Shore & Buffalo Railroad Company, then leased
it to Vanderbilt’s New York Central. He
made similar moves in Pennsylvania, Virginia,
and Ohio.
As Morgan’s personal fortune grew, so did
his clout as a Captain of Industry. In 1882,
he moved his family to a prominent brownstone
mansion at 219 Madison Avenue, three blocks
from where the Empire State Building would
eventually be built. He was a recognizable
face around New York City – not just because
of his metaphorical stature in the Finance
World, but also because of his literal countenance.
Morgan was tall and broad-shouldered, with
a great, bushy mustache, and as he grew into
middle age, his face was actually becoming
deformed. Among the maladies that Morgan suffered
from was Rosacea – a chronic skin condition
that swells and reddens much of the tissue
around the nose and cheeks. Morgan’s rosacea
was coupled with rhinophyma – the development
of a huge, overgrown, bulbous nose, which
often brings inflammation, pimples, and papules.
The combination of Morgan’s size, aggression,
and facial features made him a truly intimidating
man to be around. Other titans of the gilded
age carried a reputation for cutthroat tendencies,
but Morgan actually looked the part. To make
matters worse, he was often photographed because
of his fame, but he hated to be photographed
because he was self-conscious about his appearance.
His anger at being photographed only served
to heighten his naturally intimidating profile.
It was a vicious cycle – one that only served
to make him more intimidating and distrusted
by the public as his wealth kept growing.
If You Have to Ask…
By the time that Junius Morgan passed away
in 1890, his son had become one of the wealthiest
and most powerful men in the world. Morgan
had amassed such a combination of money and
power that he was almost single-handedly responsible
for navigating the United States economy out
of the Panic of 1893. Back when the US Dollar
was backed by gold, a financial downturn could
wipe out the national gold reserves. That’s
precisely what happened in the final years
of the 19th century.
As the US recoiled under a mountain of financial
pressure, Morgan called a meeting with US
President Grove Cleveland, offering to replenish
the US coffers from his banks. The US Government
resisted at first, exploring the idea of selling
bonds to the public, but ultimately obtained
3.5 million ounces of gold from a trust headed
by Morgan. In return, the US government issued
30-year bonds.
Morgan saved the treasury, but in doing so,
armed the Democratic Party with one of its
chief complaints in the upcoming Election
of 1896. William Jennings Bryan skewered the
cozy relationship between Republicans and
wildly powerful banks, like J.P. Morgan & Company.
Bryan’s point was proven both right and
moot when Morgan and several of his banker
friends donated heavily to the campaign of
Republican nominee William McKinley, who won
in 1896, and again in 1900.
Life was good for J.P. Morgan. He smoked Cuban
Cigars all day, every day, and purchased fine
art wherever he could find it. He was grooming
his only son, John Pierpont Jr., to join the
Morgan banking empire, just as his father
once did for him. His eldest daughter, Louisa,
married a lawyer named Herbert Satterlee who
was on track to become Assistant Secretary
of the Navy. Another daughter, Juliet, married
a man named William Pierson Hamilton, a descendent
of Alexander Hamilton. As the 20th century
approached, life in the House of Morgan was
very, very good.
Morgan became president of the Metropolitan
Museum of Art and was also a prominent leader
in the Episcopal Church. He spent a great
deal of time collecting rare gemstones; part
of his collection was displayed at the World’s
Fair in Paris in 1889. And somehow, in between
all that, and all the banking work, he was
a frequent, passionate yachter.
Morgan loved to sail; after decades of grinding
out work, he likely saw a good retreat on
one of his yachts as a well-earned respite.
One infamous story from the House of Morgan
recounts how a socialite friend of his once
asked how much the maintenance on his yacht
cost; Morgan allegedly replied that, “If
you have to ask, you can’t afford it.”
Thus, a truly American syllogism was born.
In his later years, Morgan certainly had interests
to enjoy, but it didn’t mean he wasn’t
still working. He helped fund Thomas Edison’s
initial experiments with electricity, and,
later, helped him form General Electric. Separately,
in 1898, J.P. Morgan and Co. financed the
creation of Federal Steel. Two years later,
he began negotiating with Andrew Carnegie
and Charles Schwab to buy Carnegie’s steel
business, in the hopes of merging it with
other, smaller companies. Together, those
acquisitions, as well as his own creation,
could form one massive conglomerate that succeeded
via superior logistics and infrastructure.
The result was the United States Steel Corporation,
and in 1901, it was awarded a market capitalization
of $1.4 billion dollars, making it the world’s
first billion-dollar company.
Around the same time, Morgan teamed up with
Canadian-American railroad executive James
Hill to create another new corporation, the
Northern Securities Company. This was a holding
company, designed to hold the majority shares
in Northern Pacific, Great Northern, and CB&Q
railroads. The stroke gave Morgan control
of one-third of all US Railways.
Now, in the aftermath of the Sherman Anti-Trust
Law of 1890, Morgan was careful to avoid moves
that could be seen as subverting fair market
competition. He would even go so far as to
directly check with the US President on the
legality and fairness of potential acquisitions
before buying or restructuring anything. But
the Northern Securities Company is where Morgan
finally pushed his luck one step too far.
His friend and ally, President William McKinley,
had been assassinated by an anarchist in September
of 1901. He was replaced by Vice President
Teddy Roosevelt, a headstrong populist and
avid Trust-Buster who had a much less chummy
relationship with America’s biggest banker.
Roosevelt wasted no time in using the Sherman
Anti-Trust Law to break up the Northern Securities
Company in 1902. Morgan was infuriated – he
wasn’t going to lose any money, but he had
carefully cultivated his reputation as an
untouchable financier, and he didn’t want
the black mark of an anti-trust suit on his
resume. Thus, Morgan waged a drawn-out legal
battle with Roosevelt and his government,
even though he suspected the law wasn’t
on his side as soon as the Justice Department
had sued him. The US Supreme Court upheld
Roosevelt’s decision two years later, in
1904.
Morgan remained angry with Roosevelt for the
remainder of his life, but it didn’t stop
him from helping the federal government when
it needed it… again. During the Panic of
1907, the US economy was once again in dire
straits. Several key banks were on the brink
of collapse, so Morgan did what he did best
– he leveraged his considerable political
power to get as many wealthy friends into
one room as he could, then commanded them
when, where, and how to spend their money
to stop the Panic. He used his influence to
secure otherwise unavailable lines of credit,
then bought up tons of devalued stock to inject
much-needed capital back into the economy.
He even scored a revenge win over Roosevelt
– the story is convoluted, but Morgan was
put in a position where he could save the
US economy by spending $30 million to purchase
stock in a company called Tennessee Coal & Iron,
which was a chief competitor of his company,
US Steel. By the letter of the law, the move
violated the Sherman Anti-Trust Act, but Roosevelt
had no recourse but to allow the purchase.
The Panic ended days later.
The Three Bank Legacy
Despite his stabilizing efforts during the
Panic of 1907, JP Morgan was all but retired.
Fifty years of stocks and steel in imperfect
health had left him tired and out of energy.
Understandably, he wanted to enjoy his yachts
and his art, so he spent the final years of
his life at sea and in leisure, supporting
many of the New York artists that he enjoyed,
and sailing to new parts of the world.
In 1911, the avid ship lover was excited to
take his place on the maiden voyage of the
Titanic. The Titanic was operated by the White
Star Line, which was owned by a Morgan corporation,
the International Mercantile Marine Company.
The chain of ownership meant Morgan had his
own private suite and promenade deck on the
ship. At the very last minute, though, he
decided to cancel his attendance on the maiden
voyage due to health reasons, choosing to
remain at a resort in the French Alps.
After the ship sank, he remarked, “Monetary
losses amount to nothing in life. It is the
loss of life that counts.” It’s certainly
a credible opinion, from a man who appeared
to have all the money in the world.
Morgan outlived the Titanic, but not by much.
His health began deteriorating in 1913; he
died while visiting Rome, on March 31, 1913.
He was two weeks shy of his 76th birthday.
Morgan’s legacy as both a banker and a philanthropist
is a powerful one. His personal estate was
worth $68.3 million dollars at the time of
his death; in today’s money, that would
make him a billionaire. Much of his art was
either donated to the Met or preserved in
what is now New York’s Morgan Library & Museum.
We could probably do an entire video just
on Morgan’s Art Collection, which was worth
tens of millions of dollars, even back then.
As for JP Morgan and Co, his son took over
the family business after his death. The company
included Morgan’s original business enterprise,
as well as his father’s London enterprise
that Morgan eventually took over after the
old man’s death. The London company was
restructured shortly before Morgan’s death
as Morgan, Grenfell, & Co. It remained tied
to its sister companies in the US until the
1980s; it became Deutsche Bank in 1990.
As for the US side of things, JP Morgan & Co
was forced to split itself by the Glass-Steagall
Act of 1933, which forced banks to separate
their commercial and investment elements.
J.P. Morgan & Company stayed on the commercial
side, eventually becoming J.P. Morgan Chase
at the turn of the 21st century. The speculative
side of J.P. Morgan morphed into Morgan Stanley
in 1935.
That means that J.P. Morgan, over the course
of 75 years, engineered the creation of three
of the 21st century’s most prominent banks.
And even that, arguably, wasn’t his greatest
accomplishment. His repeated support of troubled
banks, failing businesses, and a panicked
US government prompted the creation of the
US Federal Reserve. In the aftermath of the
Panic of 1907, it was clear that the US government
could no longer operate without a federal
banking system that could better control the
flow of money throughout the economy. It was
too risky to rely on the timely support of
a few ultra-wealthy power brokers to resolve
recessions; six years later, during the same
year that Morgan died, the US created the
Federal Reserve.
Despite momentous public backlash, The Federal
Reserve was a necessary action. The United
States could never again allow itself to rely
on an ultra-wealthy power broker that could
single handedly put the economy back together
again; after all, it was unlikely that there
would ever be another man like J.P. Morgan.